>> Eddie: DUMBO WITH A BIG HIT
GOURDE SCORES!
YANNI GOURDE AGAINSTHE RIGHT
SIDE OF THE ICE. YOU UP ICE WITH
STAMKOS.
STEVEN STAMKOS OVER FOR
PLAY TO GO SIDE TO SIDE AND A T
SHIFT.
NO ONE COULD SETTLE DOWN THE
>> Brandan: JOSEPH, A LITTLE
STUTTER STEP.
FAKES THS TRIP.
0 FOR 14 IN THE FIRST FIVE GAMES
OF THIS SIX-GAME ROA
EBERLE TO LAUZON.
THE DEFENSEMAN FLIPS OVEH.
BACKHAND PLAY.
THREE LIGHTNING PLAYERA THEME T.
YEAR ONE OF A SIX-YEAR DEA
BOTH GOALTENDERS HAVE BEEN
EXCELLENT SIDE TO SIDE.
A SHOS.
PLAYING IN GAME NUMBERND IT GOE
THE RIGHT.ACHING STAFF GIVING
SERGACHEV A COUPLE PATS ON BY CL
LIND.EVSKIY EVER SO
SLIGHTLY, BUT HE H H
YANNI GOURDE STEPPED UP ON HIM,
COULDN'T SECURE THCROSS HIS RIG.
A DROPPED PASS, JOHANSSON HAD TO
COME GET IT.
SERVE BLADE.
CLANK!
CROSSBAR,
HE DID SAY BEFORE THE GAME THAT
THE SECRETS TO
BRAYDEN POINT.
THE POKEHEAR YOU THINK THAT SEA
GOING TO BE ABLE TO GET THE PUCK
OUT OF THE WAY, BUT THAT'S NOT
TO BE.
I THIN.
I REALLY DON'T KNOW HOW HE SAW
IT.
I AS SWARMED BY THE
KRAKEN.
OVERSHOT, BLACKWELL.
KUCHEROV DOWN THE LEFT SIDE.
TRIED TO SET UP POINT WHO WAS G.
A LITTLE TAP PASS FROM YANNI  D0
AGAINST THE CHICAGO BLACKHAWKS.
REMARKABLEA PENALTY SHOT
AGAINST THE NEW JERSEY DEVILS,
JUST THAS TRIP.
AS KUCHEROV PLAYS TO THE BOARDS
FOR STAMKON A GAME IF WHICH IS
4-1, HE IS LOOKING AT TH